pastor legette before you go i just want
to say that i really appreciate this
conversation i think it's going to be
healing for so many women and because of
you
i'm going to flower
when it comes to relationships who
should be in the driver's seat men
or the women
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
welcome to led live it's a show where we
use the light of christ to expose the
darkness found in media and our culture
today we have pastor frank legette on
the show with us
he is well he has been in pastoral
ministry for the past 38 years and has
done life coaching for 17.
and on top of all of that he's
passionate about screenwriting and film
directing pastor laguette welcome to the
show thank you so much for being here
with us thank you for having me
now the topic for today's show is the
top three mistakes that women make and i
just want to ask mikey and brad here
what do you think are the mistakes that
women make in relationships
lack of communication
interesting so that's a woman's mistake
yeah see i grew up thinking that it was
always the women saying you don't talk
enough let's talk let's let's chat or
whatever but
i've had multiple relationships where
the women just they don't communicate
and you know there's also that thing
about how women want you to read their
mind so it's like hey do you care if i
go to dude's house
sure yeah whatever go that's like all
right cool i'm going ah see you go with
the words not the body oh my gosh
it's not always that direct
it's not always that
in your face though okay what about you
right in relationships
so
not putting themselves out there if they
want to date
sometimes especially in uh in church
settings or small group settings
you gotta venture out and and not try to
be discovered you gotta talk you gotta
do stuff otherwise you're not gonna be
you're not gonna you're not gonna reach
people yeah very interesting thing okay
we're learning we're learning a woman
might be watching this and get very
defensive what do you mean three
mistakes that women make so pastor
laguette i'd like to pose this question
to you because your your seminar is
about the mistakes that women make in in
relationships why women specifically
let me share this with you
i've worked with scores of women over
uh almost 20 years now
and here's what i've discovered
that
i've identified either 30 i've lost
track now
i've identified 30 or 31 mistakes that
women routinely make in their
relationships and these are not men's
mistakes men we make our own mistakes in
relationships i'm specifically referring
to women um and now there's no one woman
that makes all 30 and 31
but of all the women that i have ever
worked with and dealt with who have been
my
students clients whatever whatever
nomenclature you want to use
99.9 of all of them have made the top
six
hmm wow
without failure okay
and what i want to say to you is
that they
when you make mistake number one and
almost all women make this one
they are like dominoes that will
automatically drop
mistake number two and three are gonna
drop and then um
uh four and five and then quite often
number six so so
regularly routinely
these are the mistakes that women and
when they come to the program when they
come through my program and i'm working
with them they say oh my gosh
how come how come nobody explained this
20 years ago it would have kept me from
making all of these mistakes you
mentioned your training program tell us
a little bit about that before you start
going into the mistakes
um i have a ministry entitled the
women's empowerment hq
headquarters
um
it is an eight-week program
where i teach women how to experience
the love they desire
deserve
and have dreamed of
since
they were little girls
okay
i don't teach theory i teach techniques
and over the eight week period i'm
teaching technique i'm teaching how to
how to be in a relationship with a man
and get what you want and need in a
relationship with a man because here's
my experience after having passed it for
almost 40 years
um and doing what i do with women for
almost two decades now
here's my experience
most of us men and most husbands are on
cloud nine because women
make it their business to put their men
on cloud nine
many of those women particularly when
they get together and they're talking
amongst themselves
how unhappy how unfulfilled they are how
unloved they are because the love that
the women give to their men
go to them in gushes but the love that
comes back to them comes back and
trickles interesting so rarely do women
get back from their men what they give
to their men so i teach them
how to get from your man what you need
in the relationship so that you
as well as he can be happy that's an
eight-week process and and i will tell
you that at the end of the process
if they roll up their sleeves
and they master the technique starting
with the real man technique if they
master it
it's a game changer their lives change i
put them in the driver's seat in the
very next relationship they are in from
the moment a guy approaches him okay
well let's get to it let's talk about
it's a life-changing life-altering
experience
all right let's get to it let's talk
about this driver seat let's go into
mistake number one mistake number one is
it is the most egregious mistake that
women make and it starts with this one
uh and i'm going to use
a driving i'm going to use a driving
situation as a metaphor for a
relationship
because in a real life driving situation
it is the driver that determines the
speed at which
they're going to go
right
whether whether they're going to go at a
snail's pace five miles an hour six
miles an hour or if they're going to go
60 70 80 miles an hour it's the driver
that determines that it is the driver
that determines whether if if and i live
in the northeast i'm in pennsylvania if
we're going to florida if we're going to
get on 95 and go straight south or if
i'm going to start out west
and and and then go east and then go
south it is the driver that determines
that it is the driver
that is dictating the terms
of how we're driving where we're driving
whole nine yards it is the driver who
has all that power and all of that
leverage where the same thing happens in
our relationships and the mistake that
women make is
they put a man in the driver's seat in
their life
before he has earned the right to sit in
that seat in her life and here's what
women need to know and here's what i
teach them
when that man comes in
and so let me go back to the driver's
situation in a relationship um
so when a man who hasn't determined that
he knows how to be a man he hasn't
determined that he knows how to treat a
woman he doesn't know how to how to
please and take care of a woman but he's
been given the keys to her heart and her
life and her body
he is sitting in the driver's seat
number one he's dictating the speed at
which the relationship is going to go
whether whether it is going to go with
any kind of alacrity right to the altar
or not he is going to determine if that
relationship is going straight to the
altar or if that relationship is going
to go around around abraham's barn and
never get to the altar
most importantly and i want every woman
to know and understand this it is the
driver in the relationship that is
dictating the terms of the relationship
so here's what's happening in culture at
large
because in the church
the church is a female dominated
environment and competition is fierce
and so
it is the guys in the church because
women outnumber men in the church six to
seven to one what and so and so when
when the guy comes into the church he
knows he has the leverage and so here's
what a guy is saying to women i know it
because women are telling me
here's what the guy is saying oh oh oh
you said you don't want to give me any
of that really
well guess what i've got this one and
i've got that one and i've got this one
and i've got that one who will take care
of my needs so if you want to be on my
arm here's what you need to do
and guess what
women are compromising
why because you need to understand two
things there are two major points in a
woman's life 30th birthday 40th birthday
and so when a woman gets to her 30th
birthday um she is she assesses where
she thinks she should be at that point
and if mr wright is nowhere on the
horizon
her biological clock begins to tick
and
and the decibels go up and the closer
she gets to 35
those decibels become become deafening
and god forbid that she gets close to 40
and he's not on the radar screen
anywhere not only because anxiety set in
but then she begins to she can often
feel feelings of desperation and then
she realizes that that window is
beginning to close the window of child
bearing years can begin to close and the
dream of having that family that drop
dead gorgeous husband those beautiful
children that window is closing so many
women compromise here's what i want
women to know when a man walks into a
room
filled with single women and i want you
to picture this picture a a field full
of red tulips and there's one yellow
tulip i want woman to know i want women
to know that a single man walking into
that room he is not looking for the red
tulips because those are the ordinary
ones those are those are the ones who
are willing to compromise now he will he
will hop in bed with you he will drive
your car he will spend your money but
the one he will take home to mama
because mama is a deal breaker is that
one extraordinary woman who is unique
and different from everybody else
and i'm i'm here to tell you that the
overwhelming majority of the women who
come to me come to my program have not
realized that and i teach them how to be
extraordinary and unique i put them in
the driver's seat that is mistake number
one they're putting the guys in the
driver's seat before he has earned the
right to be there and many of them are
compromising out of desperation because
they think that that that vision and
that dream that they've had
will never be realized and so they're so
desperate and and so desirous of having
that dream they make compromises and it
comes back it comes back
to bite them in the new in the you know
in the you know what and so then i have
to help them to correct to correct that
mistake that's mistake number one it's
the most egregious one and when that
mistake happens mistake number two and
three is gonna drop like dominoes that
it is yeah no i think that's that's a
that's an interesting discussion uh
because i think what's really
fascinating to me is that what you said
about the the two points 30 and 40.
what i did i did some
analysis on this and what's what's
really interesting about 30s and 40s
was the statistic that says
that you can't bear children after a
certain age or that the risks of bearing
children double after that certain age
did you know
that this is not exactly statistically
true
what happens is after the age of 40 the
risks go from point five percent to one
percent
that doubles but it's not much right
what that came from
was a sale of products
it was a money thing and so isn't it
always when yeah and so i can get i can
get the statistics out for for after the
show notes but it's really interesting
to realize that this idea that's been
swelling up in society that not only men
and women believe
has come from a product that someone
wants to sell a long time ago
so so now so that that
that problem has made people say oh no i
gotta get married otherwise i'm not
gonna have kids whereas people are
having kids from a long time down the
line and they don't need to worry about
that
and we had a question on the show do you
remember um should women over 35 plus or
how should people over 35 plus manage
their expectations so it seems to be a
societal push that you should change
your expectations 35 years and older
right when that doesn't sound like the
case at all
wow
all right pastor legate mistake number
two
what is the second mistake women make in
relationships
mistake number two is
um women
quite often are violating god's biblical
blueprint for relational and marital
happiness um
there's a text in ephesians 5 25 i spent
a lot of time explaining it
uh husbands love your wives even as
christ also loved the church and gave
himself for it there are two things in
that text but i'm gonna i'm gonna refer
to another text as well first
corinthians 5 7 it says purge out
therefore the old leaven that he may be
a new lump as ye are unleavened for even
christ our passover is sacrificed for us
from those two texts here's what we
learned here's what the apostle paul
says
he's talking to
the church in um
in ephesus
and he's explaining
particularly to the husbands
that
christ is the example
husbands
you should treat your wife
the way christ treated his wife the
church
because christ in his relationship with
his wife he was the lover
he was the giver
he was the sacrificer if i can use that
word
but then when you look at the majority
of our
marital relationships
and our couples
you look at men and women in these
relationships
women have switched roles with men
majority of the women in their marriages
in their relationships are the lovers
they're the givers
and they are the sacrificers
so
both single and married women come to me
and and i have to work with them because
they're upside down in their
relationship now in scripture
particularly the garden of eden if
scripture has told us anything you
cannot compromise the word of god
without suffering consequences
god has specific roles for men and women
to fulfill and they're not
interchangeable
and so and so so many of our women are
are fulfilling the roles that god that
the apostle paul inspired by the holy
ghost said that men should be the lovers
and the givers and the sacrifices of our
lives but in most of our in many if not
most of our relationships it is the
exact opposite and so it is no wonder
why because here's what happens
in the dating process
ladies and gentlemen in the dating
process
this this this this flip begins to
happen
uh and what happens is when you change
roles with guys today it's a it's look
you we're in a different era today than
how i was raised and my father and my
grandfather uh right on back on in those
older generations it's a
different era today men and women are
functioning different today than than
than we used to in yesteryear
and what i see today is this and it's
pervasive all throughout all throughout
popular culture
when you when you when a woman switches
roles with a man
the man then becomes comfortable
in that role
and he's seen and then the guy sit back
and expect the woman to meet his needs
and then and then what happens is she's
doing the loving the giving the pleasing
the sacrificing now that might be cute
during the dating process but what
happens later in life burnout
when she's wearing the pants she's
making all the decisions
they come to me and they say pastor i am
sick and tired of being the man in this
marriage i did not get married
to be the head of this family that's not
my role
that process starts those seeds are
planted in the dating process okay
um and ultimately her happiness gets
capped he may be on cloud nine but she
may be nowhere near it um we cannot
violate the word of god without
suffering consequences we need to be the
lovers the givers the sacrifices in our
marriages that's what the word of god
says
you mention the roles that women i mean
that men play in the relationship what
is in contrast to that what is the role
that women play in relationships and in
marriage
i have something i have a book that's
coming out entitled um
mastering the forgotten art of womanhood
subtitles teaching a man to love you
the way you want to be loved without him
knowing he's been taught in that first
chapter or second chapter i believe i
talk about the genesis 2 18 principle
and i believe i believe that
one of the greatest gifts that god has
has ever given to a man is a woman
um
and and i believe that women are
strategically placed in a man's life
and i believe that what god was saying
to us is
when he gave us
women
that
i'm going to place somebody in your life
who's going to be the most influential
person in your life more than your
parents
more than your boys
more than your best friends she's going
to be the most influential individual
that that is in your life and and and so
that she can fulfill that role
of being your help meet i am going to
imbue her with her own set of gifts and
skills
and one of those gifts is i'm going to
speak to her on the frequency men that
you do not hear new nor do you
understand it that frequency uh is
called a woman's intuition and i believe
that men
who really under it really
value their women will listen to their
their women and the and the men who do
not
often end up in trouble because i
believe that god is speaking to them and
they see things that we don't see
they don't they see stuff coming that we
don't see coming a wife could say to a
husband look be careful of that one over
there and we'll say oh hey you you you
always think that somebody's interested
in
you
don't nobody wants your husband but me
and then you get down the road and what
happens
an affair happens okay um um
a woman and when you go to first samuel
and there's a technique that i teach
called the abigail technique it is the
queen of all techniques
and when you realize that david was in a
murderous ranch
and was going to nable's house to kill
all the men in that camp
and when when abigail got down off of
her donkey
i want you to understand one thing
there were 10 or 11 or 12 i'm forgetting
the exact number that she did
there were 10 11 12 things that she did
and by when she opened her mouth
david never opened his
because she was masterful in what she
did and she held up she erected a
standard for him
she said if you're gonna be the next
king of this nation
then you can't you have to be up here
you cannot deal with a fool because my
husband is a fool how do i know that
because his name nabel means fool
be a king
act like a king function and behave like
a king so i teach women
how to function like abigail's and i
will tell you i will tell you that my
wife my
wife she passed away in september
she passed away from covet
wow i'm sorry
i was a mess when we got married
she single-handedly
took me to another level in life
she erected a standard
of righteousness
for me
she said if you're gonna be my man this
is how you are going to function
and i had to live up to her standards
women are the standard bearers in our
lives
and god speaks to them and we need to
listen to them because they are change
agents in our life
and when you have a good one
she's a change agent
she makes you better she requires you to
be better and she erects a standard for
you
and she knows what the standard is
because she's in contact with god
herself
i want to go back to that women's
intuition thing i'm very curious about
that can we see that um
that in the bible anywhere when i was
processing that question myself i the
only thing i could come back to was
maybe pilate's wife as he as uh god
talked to her and said hey don't
don't uh
i've had dreams about this man don't
don't go do that can you think of any
others any other examples in the bible
about women's intuition
or dreams that's presented to
the question good question nobody's ever
asked me that question before um
i may have to uh
who's that brat was that brad yeah yeah
i may have to think about that um i may
have to give that some thought i've no
uh nobody's ever asked me that before no
problem um but he did use the example
abigail at the top of my head other than
then
well in the in the in the instance that
you just quoted
i think that was more than than
intuition sure she you know the lord the
lord came to her
and
and the vision of dream or whatever and
uh was trying to help pilot out not to
you know not to go down the road that he
ultimately went down anyhow
um so that
that may have been more than just
intuition but but just intuition look
i'm gonna have to give that some thought
that's a that's a that's a real good
question i hadn't thought about that
before do you remember the prophetess
when jesus was a baby and joseph and
mary went to the temple the prophetess
that identified anna anna anna yeah
wouldn't you say that's uh
intuition or like the holy spirit
speaking to her
uh man no i'm i'm giving
no i mean anna was a prophet test so
she was accustomed to having the holy
ghost and having and having god speak to
her
um inspiration prophetic inspiration
i i believe is definitely on a different
level than a woman's intuition
i can think of
so what about moses's mother
for when
there was just so much going on um with
was it pharaoh killing babies uh yeah it
was a pharaoh pharaoh yeah and so for
her to
know
what routes to escape and to put the
baby of course by faith in that little
basket
do you think that was intuition because
she could have just stepped out on the
street at the wrong time you know
and that's a very terrifying time in
life i i i want to
just so i can i can kind of um
put these two ideas together because
sometimes people say intuition is is
something speaking to them like the holy
spirit and other people say well it's
just a it's just a something that
happens and then i i hear i i think what
this is my personal belief i'm not
basing this on it just so i'm clear on
that but what i think
is amazing about women's brains whereas
men can focus on one thing and get it
done really fast women are taking in all
kinds of things all at once and they put
these things together subconsciously in
the mind and they go
hmm that doesn't seem right but it's not
based on something that they
hear in the back perhaps all the time
but it's the nuances and the specifics
that are subconsciously
put put back there in boxes and go
you might want to check on that
so and so because this just doesn't feel
right
when it's not a feeling it's actually
based on logic and statistics
subconsciously that's my personal belief
interesting
wow
okay pastor legate number three what is
the third mistake top mistake that women
make in relationships
um violating god's biological blueprint
for relational and marital happiness
when god created
adam and eve
created mankind
because of his full knowledge he knew
that at the end of time mankind would
forget how to be in right relationships
with one another
he knew that that at the end of time in
the last days
that men and women were going to switch
roles with one another he knew um
that
um
same-sex marriages
would proliferate
and be legalized in this country and
around the world he knew all of that
and so what he did is put a teaching
device within our dna
that we cannot gain say
and he teaches us
through this internal
biological physiological
teaching device
how we should function
in relationships
with one another males to females
and so in a sexual context
man and a woman
that sexual context
is in harmony
with ephesians 5 25.
um
um that the man is the lover and the
giver
and so if the man is the is the giver
in uh in the relationship
that means the woman is the receiver
of that love
it is also true in a sexual context
the man is the is the is the giver and
the woman is the receiver
the man is giving the sexual organ the
woman is receiving it the man is giving
the sperm the woman is receiving the
sperm
now let's talk about the sperm
because because you got two things you
got sperm you got egg in a sexual
context when a man ejaculates into a
woman the vagina is an incredibly acidic
environment and millions are killed on
contact
and only the strong survive
and it is the sperm
that has one objective
and it has been programmed by god
to fulfill one objective
and that is
it has been programmed
to seek
and penetrate
an egg
it has not been programmed to seek and
penetrate another sperm
that would be homosexuality
it is it is other directed and not sane
directed
wow
and you got to look at the sperm in the
egg because each of them
represent the characteristics
of the person that they come from so the
sperm comes from
the male
consequently it has male characteristics
if you look at the sperm itself there's
two components to it it has a head
and it has a tail
why does it have a head
scripture is real clear ephesians i
believe it's 5 23
husbands
you are the heads of your wife
why does it have a tale
it is mobile it was designed by god to
be the pursuer
and not the pursued
if you look at the egg
in an ovulating woman every month an egg
is produced
and through the fallopian tubes it
pushes it along and ends up in the
fallopian tubes
and for 28 days is what it does it does
this
it sits
like a flower
and because it does not have a tail
it is immobile it is incapable of
pursuing an egg why
because god never designed a woman to
pursue a man because when she does one
she's putting the man in the driver's
seat in a relationship number two she's
she's negotiating from a position of
weakness number three she's surrendering
all of her power in the relationship and
ends up powerless number four she's
bought she's violating her her
biblical blueprint for relational
happiness number five
she's violating her biological blueprint
for relational and marital happiness
and she's going to cap her happiness
because she's upside down in the
relationship she's going to make her man
incredibly happy because she's going to
give and give women give to
receive and when the relationship is not
right
women conclude you know what you know
what you know what what then i'm just
going to give more
i'm gonna i'm gonna bake more cakes i'm
gonna bake more pies i'm gonna be a
better cook i'm gonna get more sex i'm
gonna do whatever she gives and gives
and gives it in an effort and a desire
to get back
and unfortunately for many for many
women
it doesn't come back
the way she gives it so many
women are unfulfilled unhappy and
unsatisfied but it's to be expected you
cannot violate god's word
without suffering consequences and many
women are upside down and i help to
write them
whether they're single or married so i
have married women right now going
through they're about to they're writing
their situations
they come to me frustrated
men uncompliant
insensitive
and i teach them some techniques and
they and they turn this ship around and
she ends up happy
um um
but you got to follow god's word there's
no substitute for following god's word
there is no substitute
because god's word is real clear so i
have a question so
were all both men and women
driven to find a significant other
if it's women's role
primarily not to
seek
and men's role to find that woman
what advice do you give to women who
need to find that fulfillment because
often like i said at the beginning
i've seen the mistake that i believe is
happening is women go to church for an
hour and they leave and say i just
wasn't discovered
i would i would personally i believe and
tell me if i'm wrong than this
they need to go to every group they need
to go they need to stand up in front of
the church they need to start a ministry
they need to do stuff that gets them
seen so they can be discovered what do
you think
i agree i agree with that 100 you cannot
look you cannot
you could uh let's go back uh 30 years
before the onset just to make this make
this um um
illustration more realistic
because now you can do you can shop for
a job online but before there was online
right if you wanted a job you had to
leave your home you could not say to god
oh god i want a job i want a job i want
to work nobody will give me a job but
you never leaving the house
that didn't make any sense in that
environment it's changed today of course
well ladies you got to go to singles
retreats you got to visit other if there
are no men in your church if there's no
men in your church you got to go to
another church you got to go where where
where their events are taking place
here's what a look look i'm gonna use
another metaphor there's there's the
there's the bee
and there's a flower
flowers don't chase bees
right what do flowers do sit there
anyways
flowers emit an incredible aroma and
they draw and attract men what does the
egg do if you study the egg it comes
down the fallopian tube
the egg submits a signal and lets the
egg let the sperm know hey guys
no you're heading the wrong direction
guys i'm over here
but she never pursues them
well
she emits a powerful signal that lets
them know where she is but she she can't
go after them because she has no tail
god is saying to you follow the
principles that i've outlined that i put
in your very dna follow those principles
so a woman a woman just like just like
just like a device you get a new phone
you get a new laptop
if you if you want to connect it's got
to be discoverable
ladies have to make themselves
discoverable don't leave the house i
tell the ladies in my program look i
don't care if you're going down to the
store
don't leave the house looking like
booger bear when you go to the house you
gotta look
because you don't you don't know when mr
wright is going to show up
[Music]
so i'm going to tell you this story my
daughter
my wife and two of my daughter i got
three daughters two of my daughters were
going out to the mall
and my one daughter this ministry
started because i started working with
that daughter and so and so my daughter
got dressed up and she put a in a nice
sundress and she put a flower in her
hand and and my wife and my other
daughter said
keisha
why are you all dressed up we just going
to the mall she said cause pop-pop said
i'm a flower
and she met
the most incredible guy
ever
they had three incredible kids happier
than they've ever been
but you got to do it god's way wow pasta
lagette
i actually have a question
how
do
women
i guess attract or pursue without
actually pursuing
because that's kind of
like you have to be at the places but
it's like
do you have to be the loudest one in the
room do you have to be the most flashy
in the room like you know like making
yourself known i guess i'm just trying
to get some clarification on that how do
you flower
yes how do you flower
all right that's a good that's a good
question nobody's ever asked that one
before um
i think number one it starts with you
well first of all let's understand this
let's understand one thing
here's what i teach all the women in my
program i got a new class starting march
6. i got it one class is ending next
sunday night and new class starts the
following sunday march 6. here's what i
teach
and it doesn't even start with them
it starts with him
proverbs 3 no no no no no psalms 37 4
delight thyself in the lord and he shall
give thee
the desires
of thine heart
here's what god is saying
delight yourself in me
and i'm going to give you what you want
because i want you to have i want you to
be happy and i want you to want with you
and it's okay for you to want what you
want so this is not all on you
you're talking to me you're praying to
me
i know who you need i know what you need
you do your part i'm gonna do mine
because i know where mr wright is you
don't follow my guidance follow my
direction listen to my voice so it's not
all on the woman it is not all on the
woman or all on the man
because when god is in control of your
life he is orchestrating the the affairs
and the events of your life he knows how
to bring mr right to the event that
you're going to and he will whisper in
that man's ear
when i met my wife 30 years ago
i got on a plane and i went to it's on
my youtube channel frankie legit
deserved i went to lake placid florida
and the morning before i left i said
i had a conversation with myself
i sat me down and here's what i said to
me because i had just ended a
relationship
i said frank
you need time to heal
so you're going to go down here you're
going to have an incredible time with
all of these people
the majority of which are going to be
incredible women and you know what
you're going to go down because you're
you're you're a very sociable guy you're
a great guy you know you're good-looking
guy whole nine yards i gave myself all
those accolades right
and i said you're gonna go down and
you're gonna have a great time but
you're not coming back with any numbers
and i went down there and my very first
presentation
i stood up to speak
it was literally after eight o'clock
and from my bed from my vantage point i
could see all the women that that are
coming in now i was very proud of myself
that i hadn't met anybody i hadn't taken
down any numbers up until that point
from friday morning about six o'clock
until friday evening at eight o'clock no
numbers no i'm sticking to my plan i got
a plan i'm gonna do this whole weekend
no numbers and that plan i i carried
that plan to perfection until about a
little after eight o'clock when she
walked in the door
and my plan went directly out the window
and when she walked in the door i looked
at her i said o-m-g
who is that
and here's what god revealed to later on
29 years later he just revealed it to me
the other day you thought
you thought that just because the day
that that
singles retreat ended that you called
her on the phone and you express your
interest in her and then you called her
even though she had a boyfriend um you
you called her monday and talked for an
hour and a two and you called it tuesday
and talked an hour or two you talk
called wednesday talk for hour two and
thursday and friday you didn't call
saturday because he came down on sabbath
and then sunday she broke up with him
because of something he did saturday
night
and y'all were together from that day
november 17
1992 until september 3rd
2021 when she passed away from covert
you thought that because your rap you
know your conversation was all that you
thought that that was all about you
wrong answer
that was about me
i orchestrated that for you i determined
that that was the life that you needed
by your side
and when he revealed that to me i cried
like a baby
because i thought i had done that
wow
he set the whole thing up
and so we need to understand
when you walk out the door
it's not just all on you you have a god
on your side that's right he knows what
you want and what you need
and he will lead you guide you and
direct you my favorite text in scripture
proverbs 3 5 and 6 trust in the lord
with all that i might and lean not into
thine own understanding in all thy ways
acknowledged him and he shall
direct thy path it's not all on you
you need to do your part you need to get
your behind parts out of your church
where no men are
and you need to go out and mingle mix
and mingle and let god do what god does
because he knows how to bring mr right
to the event that you're at
now you need to look your butt you need
to look your best
amen amen
look your best
okay
uh as best you can look
um and um it's not all on you
you have a god you have a god
an invisible god
who's working
and he's working on his timetable and
not ours right may not happen when we
want it to happen
because the mr right that he has for you
may not be available right now
so we got to wait on god's timetable and
when god is ready for it to happen it
happens
that's what we have to understand
so i have another question so
what advice would you have for women who
have heard
men say or approach them saying god told
me that you're my future wife
because i know i've heard that multiple
times and i've come to the point where i
distrust that statement that statement
does not
impress me whatsoever
you know so what advice do you have to
to women who
men just approach them and say this
that is a conclusion that two people
must come to
if they're gonna if they're gonna show
up at a church
at some point in the future and walk
down the aisle and exchange and exchange
ideas
it is not enough
for him to say it and believe it with
all his heart and soul
it's not enough
he must demonstrate that
he must be
vetted he must go through a process
where he's willing to demonstrate that
that yes god said this but i am willing
to demonstrate to you that i am the man
for you if he can do that then maybe if
he can't
see ya
that's right
great answer
all right well thank you so much pastor
leget for your time
you have such a wealth of knowledge and
information and it seems like a passion
to get this information out there
you mentioned you have a youtube channel
and also a class a course coming up
please give that information what's the
name of your youtube channel and how can
people get in touch with you if they
want to join your course
um the women's empowerment hq is my site
it's also my my my youtube channel it's
the name of the ministry the women's
empowerment hq
um it starts
march 6 6 p.m
we're gonna go for eight weeks
uh i'm going to pour into these women
like like like never before
uh i um and i'm going to tell you
that
it is going to be a life-altering
life-changing experience
and the women are going to conclude at
some point in the process
and say
omg
where was this 20 30 years ago it could
have saved me from making a lot of
mistakes
um
but we're going to have a we're going to
have an incredible time
um there's a there's an incredible
bonding that takes place i don't teach
theory i teach techniques i teach how to
teach your man and here's the uniqueness
of my ministry
how to teach a man to love you the way
you want to be loved and not the way
he's accustomed to loving his women how
to love you on your terms and not his
because if he loves you the way you want
to be loved he'll get it right 100 of
the time if we love you the way we know
how to love you
it's a crapshoot
may get it right most likely he will not
because there are so many unhappy
unfulfilled unsatisfied wives and women
in the world today
because we think
because you are the one and only expert
and here's why there's some teaching
that must be done
i taught this concept to my daughter
i said you're gonna have to teach your
husband how to love you the way you want
to be loved she said pop-pop i don't
want to i don't want i don't want to
teach my husband i got three kids i
don't have one more that's right
you're gonna teach him
because
i don't care who he's been with in his
lifetime he's never been with you you
are the one and only expert on the
planet who knows how you want to be
loved you need to teach him that
my wife taught me that i was a mess when
i got married 29 years ago
she taught me how to love her on her
terms not mine
um it's a game-changing concept
and it's about creating
a two-way affair not just one-sided
where all the love is going to him and
the love trickles back to her that's
unacceptable to god
it's unacceptable to women and they
don't have to have it and those who come
through my claws my course
that's what they experience when they
roll up their sleeves
and they master the techniques that i
teach them
okay well thank you again so much pastor
laguette and if any of you are
interested in the women's empowerment hq
course the link will be in the
description underneath this video also
this is a community led live little
light studios are trying to develop a
community if you have
any other
mistakes or examples that come to mind
leave that in the comment section below
if you have been in a relationship and
there are some things that you did that
you would like to pass on to other
people about your success in
relationships or maybe some things that
you've learned from failures put that in
the comment section below so we can
dialogue and grow and learn together in
jesus christ thank you so much for
watching we'll see you next week on led
live
pastor legette before you go i just want
to say that i really appreciate this
conversation i think it's going to be
healing for so many women and because of
you
i'm going to flower
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you